Okay, I know this is a really bad idea but I'm already here so here we fucking go
Ta-ra!
Actually Nasa's bun is only a oom, he's the one
Couldn't help but notice, yo, watch from across the floor
Nasa's unique, he'll wake up, tell them we're cheating, hee-hee
I'm sucy baggy, I spin too baby, use your musky
Take me home, bet me and make me a thug
I got this stuff, me see me like my way to baby
Tell her I'm free, about you all day
Jesus, I'm like, it's your neck
I hope that you like it
Nozzles and nozzles, your chest
I'd be getting thirsty
Hey, I got a little itch
You think you can help me?
Only seven inches long
Ooh, please, adapt me
Fasten your bolchers, I like my lips
I have to hit them with this for your shit
When I get coming
You